uh so uh camille i definitely want to
jump in and start with where did this
idea come from
oh uh yes yes i um i've spent many many
years being ashamed of as a parent
thinking i'm a terrible human being and
that i brought my children up very badly
and i've come to terms with the fact
that maybe i haven't done such a bad job
um because i'm quite dark-minded and i
think we have a kind of hilarious
household but we do talk i do invite the
conversations into the home and i don't
believe in forcing trauma on anyone
especially not my children but the
conversation happens they
they they just watched warhorse and much
like that done so i keep getting there
and they said mom what are we going to
do when uh there's a war and i said well
sadly if there's a war now it's going to
be a much more serious kind of war and i
remember as a kid
raymond briggs do you know who raymond
briggs is
i've heard that this is no man
he is an incredible um animator in in
england uh he wrote cartoons and they
made them into films but he made an
animation film which you might like you
might want to call where the wind blows
and it was a cartoon about two working
class old people who are living in a
cabin during a nuclear war and i
remember as a child watching it and
feeling utterly traumatized completely
traumatized thinking of the nuclear war
so i think this this this horror of a
nuclear war the world and he's stayed in
me since i've watched that film as a
child so maybe i wanted to do the same
to my children i hope not um but i i
said to my kids well i don't know what
we'll do we have a choice of whether we
run around the forest with a gun and try
and save our lives or we end up eating
each other or we just cuddle up in bed
and say goodbye um and it's a very
extraordinary uh actually traumatizing
conversation to have but how do you what
do you say to your kids when they ask
you what we're going to do if there's a
war it's like well there is no nice way
of having that conversation so
um
yeah what was the question
why did i make the film i wanted to make
a film because i wanted to talk about
all the things that i'd like to talk
about or feel obligated to talk about
but to make them fun and entertaining
and not too traumatizing which i don't
think i have necessarily achieved but i
think that the conversation should be
had in in our in our world that's that's
why i wanted to make the film
uh for kira and uh and lily rhodes uh i
would imagine this is an interesting
script and i'm curious because it's it's
one movie until it isn't and i'm just
curious if your agents and the people
that gave you the script told you
anything about what this was or just
says or just said read this and tell me
what you think
i i gotta read this and tell me what you
think i i got i got uh i got three of my
agents all phoning up going
we really like this but you might hate
it
i was like oh i'm intrigued already this
is great
uh yeah i you know i mean i i've said
this before i was very pregnant when i
read the script so it massively uh it
really
um
it worked with my major hormones that
were going on at that moment it worked
with the fact that i'd been sick for
about six months of the pregnancy and
then i had sciatica and i was suddenly
lying in a swimming pool and i read the
script and i was just i thought it was
the most hilarious thing i'd ever read
um and then uh and then i met kami six
weeks after i had the baby and equally
very very hormonal and again i thought
it was hilarious but you know we've been
talking about a bit before it it was
i think it really fed into this kind of
idea of the maternal catastrophe
you know it's like when you give birth
to a child you give birth to life but
you also give birth to fear that you've
never experienced before
um and and i really felt like this spoke
to the kind of deeply dark maternal
side and and in this moment where we're
looking for kind of female stories and
we're looking for female storytellers i
think still
maternity is one of the the parts of
female storytelling that is still quite
taboo and particularly the darker sides
of maternity um and i felt like in a
very funny very unique weird way this
this utterly spoke to that side of my
psyche which i hadn't seen in film
before um and uh yeah and i i was i was
very excited by that i i do have to say
that we started filming when my kid was
then five months old and i was not
hormonal and she was sleeping through
the night and i then read it again and
went what the [ __ ] is this
oh my god this is the darkest thing ever
so you know i i mean i i think it's a
deeply hormonal film and that's why i
love it so much
yeah
lilly
yeah yeah sorry i'm sorry what was the
the original question was about this
how did the how did your uh your agents
or your reps present this script to you
did you know what was going to happen or
did they just say read this
um no i didn't know exactly what was
gonna happen i feel like it would have
been a shame to you know to to to spoil
that before i got a chance to crack into
it by my by myself i did get a hint that
there was it was something with a crazy
twist and so i was like reading it and
like waiting for the trick because you
know you've seen the
movie i've seen you start off and it's
like really funny and it's sweet and
you're like oh this is a nice group
right i think right and then like you
know as it goes on and on and on then
the twist happens and everything and and
that's when i was really uh
really hooked i mean i think this story
is so
like fiercely uh unique and um
and bold and you know just just like
cami and when i met cami i just was like
i am so obsessed with this woman i so
badly want to be a part of her of her
film and i and i and i really really
loved my my character and her story and
i was and i was heartbroken by it i mean
i think that it's you know
as we talk about motherhood and and uh
the the kind of maternal catastrophe
that that is happening for a lot of the
characters in this film and that
informed you know cami's writing and
directing of the movie um i really like
the place that my character sat in that
because she
um you know is is kind of in between you
know she's an outsider she's not part of
the original group she's there because
she's james's girlfriend she's not
necessarily like loved by the rest of
the group and so there's like a little
bit of a
distance there and everything and and
she's you know living with this horrible
pain of of of
you know almost bringing a child into
the world and wanting so badly to be a
mother and feeling your uh child alive
in your in your stomach and knowing that
you're not going to be able to give them
um any sort of a life i mean i think
that when we meet her she's in this kind
of horrible
um
indescribable heartbreak of of
of that you know
motherhood that's not going to be and so
i think that that's a really um you know
she represents another part of the kind
of maternal catastrophe that we're
talking about um and i and i really like
the place that she
you know occupied in that
uh i have like 17 questions and i was
told that one i can ask one more
question i don't know what to ask i'm
overwhelmed by because how much i want
to talk about um uh
[ __ ] um i guess i'm gonna i guess i want
to bring up roman davis because he's so
good in the movie and his brothers are
so good um and and all of you you guys
all have you know obviously you all
worked with him
uh can you talk about what surprised you
about working with him because he's only
made this is a second movie and it's
almost like he is like this is his 30th
film with how good he is roman is so i
just want to say i'm going to let
everybody else talk about roman and
camius's mother so she should talk about
him the most but i had a lot of my
scenes with roman and our characters are
like really
linked in this really beautiful way
because i feel like sophie you know has
a really particular connection to the
children because she's like with child
and she knows she's not going to have
the child and also because she you know
shares more of the the morals that are
like you know arts morals than the rest
of the adults they have this really
specific and really beautiful
connection and so i had a lot of scenes
with roman and he is just like
staggeringly talented it was really so
impressive to to just see him work face
it like i remember that scene that we
did on the on the bed when they're
talking and it's a really big moment for
roman and everything just watching him
do the scene i was just like i can't
believe what i'm seeing in front of my
eyes right now he's so like such a
beautiful he's such a beautiful person i
adore him and he's just so talented i
can't wait to see what he does with the
rest of his career and life i have to
say very quickly i think the cast need a
lot of credit with
with because
one of the reasons where lily was cast
i'd say
as equal other than wanting to work with
lily and understand in knowing that
lilly would understand me in the project
is that roman he physically changed
around her we went to have a tea with
her in the hotel in l.a and he his
he i've never seen him do this around
girls and women he completely changed
and i thought wow we have to put that in
the film and and kyra and matthew with
roman was so supportive of him i think
he is an exceptional actor and i'm very
proud of him in his acting but
everyone gave him so much space to do
his best work and they helped him there
was a scene that cyrus talked about
another interview where she took his
face
in her hands because he he found the
scene so intimate and difficult to see
in the car and she held his because he
wouldn't look at her and i got to the
point i was screaming i was like [ __ ]
look her in the face we were losing our
light your dad said we can't shoot the
scene it was hell into a degree because
we the scene was so important and and
kira took his hands and her face and
it's so beautiful and
about seeing it so the scenes that that
roman has with with kyra
and lily rose i think it's kind of
amazing it's actually interesting having
this conversation about motherhood and
parenting because
i
everyone kind of parented him in a way
uh not because he needed it because he
was
you know struggling but
it was a very loving environment and
safe environment even though it was so
hyper dysfunctional the material and but
he i was really lucky i think i have to
give the cast an awful lot of credit for
taking having the courage to be in the
film
and then for supporting my children the
way they did because i couldn't do it
all there was too much to do you know
completely um i'm being told to wrap up
um so here i'm gonna i'm gonna stop you
there but i really mean this when the
film down the road is coming out i
really do have other questions and i
would really like to do follow-ups
because my list of i really enjoyed this
movie and there's a lot of stuff i'd
like to talk about um so hopefully i'm
happy to do that i can't talk for the
ladies but you're that i
obviously i'm really excited to hear you
like the film so much so you can reach
out to me whenever you like
but i'm being completely serious i would
love to talk more especially with all
three of you i really did have a lot of
other questions uh congrats on the movie
i hope it gets awesome reviews and um
please let me know how i can help
promote it on collider um because i
would love to help you with however we
can do it you know amazing that's very
kind thank you so much thank you thank
you you guys have a fantastic day thank
you thank you